[MUSIC PLAYING]
Actually, it always
makes me laugh
when I hear that introduction.
And I'm introduced
as the Professor
for the Public
Understanding of Science.
Because I think
everyone expects that I
must know the whole
of science, and here I
am to explain it to
the Royal Institution.
And certainly when I took over
this job, a lot of journalists
really did expect
that I knew it all.
And I would get phone
calls from journalists just
asking me to explain every
bit of science out there.
I remember one
particular occasion,
we'd just had the Nobel Prizes
announced over the last week.
And I remember the
Nobel Prize for medicine
had just been announced.
And this journalist phoned
me up and said, yes, just
been announced for the
discovery of telomeres.
Could you tell me
what a telomere is?
And I was like, well, I'm afraid
biology is not my strong point.
So, I'm very
embarrassed to admit
that I was in fact in front
of my laptop at the time,
and I quickly pulled up the
Wikipedia page for telomeres
and then read very quickly
and confidently told
the journalist, yes, they're
the piece at the end of DNA
which controls how
long the DNA will last.
And the journalist
seemed quite happy.
But I realised at that
point, well, this is crazy.
You know, I can't be
expected to know it all.
Actually, you know, who
was the last scientist that
probably did know all the
science that was around
at the time?
I mean, maybe Newton or Galileo.
But certainly Newton,
the explosion of science
that happened post-Newton means
that probably after that, there
wasn't a scientist
that really could
say that they knew
all the science that
was known at the time.
But it sort of got me
thinking, actually,
about the question of whether--
well, could science know it all?
Not one scientist,
but could there
come a point where
science might know it all?
Or might there be questions
that by their very nature
will always be beyond the
power of science to know?
So, that's what I've been on.
It's a kind of journey
for the last three years,
trying to articulate whether
there are any questions that
by their nature might be
beyond the ability of science
to be able to answer them.
So, this is what I want to
tell you a little bit about,
this three-year journey I've
been on, culminating in this
book, What We Cannot Know.
I think that kind of expectation
that science might know it
all is partly fueled by the
fact that every time you
open the newspaper,
there seems to be
another extraordinary
discovery that we've made.
And certainly since
I took over this job,
the sort of things
that we have discovered
are absolutely extraordinary.
We landed a spaceship the
size of a washing machine
on the side of a comet.
We've managed to
create robots which
have made their own language.
They're communicating
with each other.
And we actually don't know
what this language is.
Machine learning has
given them the power
to create their own language.
We've got to interact
with these robots
to understand what it is
they're talking about.
We've sequenced the DNA of
a 50,000-year-old cave girl.
And we're starting
to use stem cells
to repair the pancreas
of diabetic patients.
So, it is kind of extraordinary
just how much we know.
And I think it's given us that
expectation that, wow, yeah,
maybe science might
come to a point
where we can answer all the big
questions about the universe.
And I think that desire to
know is incredibly basic in us.
I think it's almost as basic
as the desire to reproduce.
It's sort of what has helped us
in our evolutionary survival.
And actually, I start the book
with a quote from Aristotle
from Metaphysics.
He declares at the opening
of the book, "Everyone
by nature desires to know."
But I think it's probably
very dangerous at any point
in history to
declare, well, we're
never going to be
able to answer this.
Because it's quite difficult
to know what it is that's
just going to be
around the corner.
I mean, when is there going
to be a new Einstein which
completely revolutionises
our kind of perspective
on the universe.
So, I kept a few stories in
mind just as a warning to me
about declaring that this
is a question we will never
be able to answer.
One of my favourites was
Auguste Comte who, in 1835,
very confidently declared, "We
shall never be able to study
by any methods the chemical
composition of stars."
And you know, it seems
a very fair comment.
We still haven't visited a
star, dug a bit out of it,
and been able to
chemically analyse it.
But of course,
what Auguste Comte
hadn't reckoned on
was well, actually,
although we haven't
visited a star,
every night, the star visits us.
So, the light from the
star several decades later
scientists are able to analyse.
And we have a very
complete description
of what stars are made out of.
So, I kept this as a kind of
little warning story to me that
to declare that something cannot
be known is like a red rag
to most scientists.
Of course, you know,
I'm not the first
to kind of consider
questions of unknowns.
One of our famous 21st century
philosophers, Donald Rumsfeld--
[LAUGHTER]
--very famously summed
up states of knowledge
in this very cryptic
answer that he
gave to questions about weapons
of mass destruction in Iraq.
He declared, "There
are known knowns,
there are the things that
we know that we know.
We also know that there
are known unknowns.
That is to say, we know there
are some things we do not know.
But there are also
unknown unknowns.
Those are the ones we
don't know we don't know."
[LAUGHTER]
And he got given the
Foot in the Mouth Award
by the Plain English
Speaking Society
for this response, which I
think is actually really unfair.
Because I think this is
a fantastic description
of different states
of knowledge.
The known knowns, the things
that we have discovered.
And in fact, the book is very
much about the things we know
and how we'd known
them, and how they've
changed, how our view of
the universe has changed.
So, this is very
much a book trying
to understand how we know
the things that we do know.
The unknown unknowns, well,
they're very exciting.
They're the things
I can't tell you
about because they are unknown.
They're a bit like those black
swan events, the things which
just come out of nowhere
and completely change
your perspective
on the universe.
Those are the exciting
things for science,
but by their nature, I
cannot tell you about those.
So I'm after, in
this book, actually
trying to pin down the known
unknowns and not the things
that we don't know
now and we might know.
Are there things that will
always remain unknowable?
Actually, I think
Donald Rumsfeld
missed a category here,
which are the unknown knowns.
[LAUGHTER]
Which actually, as
Slavoj Zizek pointed out,
fairly significant
for a politician
because there your kind
of Freudian beliefs,
your delusions, the things
that you deny that you know
but actually drive
all your decisions.
So, maybe he missed
one category here.
So, but I'm after these
known unknowns that
might remain always unknowable.
Now, one of the
other motivations
for this journey I've been
on for the last three years
is also partly to do with
the person that I took
over this job from, a
certain Richard Dawkins who,
as well as talking a lot
about evolutionary biology,
spent a lot of the latter
end of his professorship
talking not about science
but talking about religion.
The god delusion got him
into a lot of arguments
with various theologians.
So, I kind of
braced myself when I
took over this job for questions
not just about telomeres
and science, but for questions
about my religious beliefs.
So, I actually prepared
a little response to them
because I sort of wanted to
put a little bit of distance
from that debate
and to move back
to sort of the public
understanding of science.
So, I actually, when journalists
would ask me this question,
I would say--
actually, declare that I'm
a deeply religious man.
And they were quite shocked
by this, quite excited.
And before they
got too excited, I
went on to explain that
my religion is the Arsenal
Football Club--
[LAUGHTER]
--and every Saturday, I
go and worship my idols
at the Emirates, formerly
Highbury Stadium.
Every season I reaffirm my faith
that this will be the season
that we win the premiership.
And each season my faith seems
to be tested at the moment.
But do we have any Spurs
fans in the audience?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, look, they're all
in the front row here.
Well, at least we have a very
good saint, St. Totteringham,
who always ensures
that Arsenal are
above Tottenham
in the premiership
by the end of the season.
It was a very late
arrival by our saint
this year because it was the
last day that he actually
came and made sure that
we ended up on top.
So, that was my religion.
Many journalists
were happy with that.
But some were a little
bit more persistent.
They said, no, come on, OK.
What are your beliefs?
And I remember especially one
Sunday morning on Northern
Ireland BBC Radio on a
philosophy and religion
programme, so, Northern
Ireland, Sunday morning,
religion isn't too far
from people's thoughts.
And I decided to go
on this programme.
And I said, well, I'm very happy
to talk about the philosophy
of science.
But I really want to stay clear
of the religion questions.
And the journalist
seemed quite happy
and the little light went
red, and we went live.
And then he went,
(IRISH ACCENT) so,
Marcus, do you believe in God?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, now, sorry.
That was a dreadful
northern accent--
Northern Ireland accent.
I won't do those anymore.
So, you know, the agreement
went out the window immediately.
And we were straight
into a debate
about the existence of god.
And so, we had kind of a
quite heated to and fro.
And at some point, I--
you see, actually,
as a mathematician,
I spend a lot of time proving
the existence of things
or proving that certain
things cannot exist.
For example, Andrew Wiles with
Fermat's Last Theorem proved
that solutions cannot be
found for these equations.
So, actually, we've got powerful
tools to prove that things
exist or they don't.
But if you're a
mathematician, you
need a very clear
definition of what
it is you're trying to
prove exists or not.
So, I pushed the journalist,
and I said, OK, look,
I'm prepared to engage my kind
of logical, mathematical mind
on this.
But I need a very
clear definition
of what it is you mean by god.
So, the journalist
then said, ah,
but it's something which
transcends definition.
It's beyond the ability
of the human mind to know.
And either way, you've just
wiped me out of the game.
How can we actually
engage with that?
And I sort of went
away from the interview
feeling a bit frustrated.
But actually, it
sort of worked on me,
that idea of god as defined
as the things we cannot know,
the things which transcend
our understanding.
And so, I began to
sort of play with that
as an interesting idea.
Well, yeah, what are those
things that we will never know,
and what sort of
role might they play?
Actually, as a god.
And actually, a few
years ago, I took part
in a debate with the Chief
Rabbi during Jewish book week.
And he wrote this
wonderful book called
"Science and Religion,
The Great Partnership,"
about how actually, science
and religion are involved
in similar kind of big--
trying to answer
the big questions.
And in preparation
for that debate,
I actually talked to a
philosophy friend of mine
at New College in
Oxford, trying to prepare
for talking to the Chief Rabbi.
And this philosopher
actually referred me
to a very interesting
theologian, Herbert McCabe.
He was actually a Marxist
theologian in Oxford.
Get that, quite cool.
A Marxist theologian.
He has a lot of kind of strange
texts on Christian liturgy
and things like that.
But there was one
essay that I read
which was very interesting
because in it, he
makes the following statement,
"To assert the existence of God
is to claim that there
is an unanswered question
about the universe."
And actually, he goes on to say
that many religions committed
iconoclasm actually by giving
this quite abstract idea far
too many properties that
it never should have had.
And of course, that's
what we get served up
as kids, this kind of
rather silly version.
And we reject it quite quickly.
I certainly did when I came
up to my comrades in school
and started learning
a bit of science.
And just, the other thing
didn't make sense at all.
But maybe we throw too
much out with that.
And maybe there
is still something
interesting to tease out
as kind of the unknowns.
And of course,
they were always--
the god was those unknowns,
volcanoes or earthquakes,
or things.
But as science has gotten
to know more and more,
that sort of unknown has
gotten smaller and smaller.
In fact, there's a term,
the God of the gaps, which
you may have heard
of, which actually
was a derogatory term created by
theologians saying that science
isn't kind of eliminating God,
that we're meant to know God.
So, it was actually
a derogatory term.
But partly, my
mission in this book
was just to explore
whether we could reclaim
the God of the gaps as
actually a positive thing
and whether it actually
has some value.
By identifying things
beyond science,
might they have something
interesting to say
about that idea.
So, I sort of kept
that in mind as well
on my journey into the unknown,
to the edges and beyond.
So, the book, I
divided up into edges.
I've got seven
edges of knowledge
that I believe have perhaps
potential for questions
that might be beyond
the world of science.
So, I want to give you a
little bit of a guided tour.
And we'll go into depth
in a couple of them.
And I'll show you some
of the other challenges
that I think are out there.
I'm just going to start
with the first edge
because that's very much at
the heart of my own subject
of mathematics.
And this is the challenge
of can we know the future
before it becomes the present?
Can we predict what's
going to happen next?
And a lot of us want to do that.
We really need to
know in order to be
able to plan what's going to
happen next and make decisions.
We would like to have
that kind of knowledge.
So, is it possible to know
what's going to happen next?
Naturally, on my journey
to the edges of knowledge,
I took with me an
object in each edge.
So, each edge has
an object associated
with it, which kind of gives me
a useful tool to kind of tease
out this particular challenge.
So, the object I took
with me on my journey
to the edge of trying to predict
the future was an object which
I think really sort
of captures the idea
of the unknowable,
the unpredictable.
It's a casino dice.
So, I mean, the
excitement of a dice
is that we don't know
what's going to happen
when we throw it on the table.
So, this time I got a six.
But there's a kind of
feeling like, oh, come on,
surely actually
science could know.
I mean, mathematics
has a lot of tools
to be able to work out what's
going to happen as that falls,
hits the table, rolls.
And certainly, I
thought that maybe, you
know, the mathematical things
I've learned over the years,
perhaps, I could use
these to actually cash
in and make a lot of money.
So, I went off to Vegas.
And I went to the craps tables.
And I decided, yeah, this is
just a problem in dynamics.
I can analyse this.
And I tried to
apply my maths to be
able to make some predictions
about how this falls.
Unfortunately, I
lost a lot of money.
[LAUGHTER]
But they let me keep the
casino dice we played with.
So, this is actually
the casino dice
that I brought back from Vegas.
But you know, I think,
how unknowable is this?
And I think it's
my hero, I guess,
in this story is Isaac Newton.
Because he did give us the tools
to give us that kind of belief
that actually we
should be able to know
what this is going to do next.
The laws of motion
tell us how this
is going to fall from
my hand, what's going
to happen when it-- oh, gosh.
[LAUGHTER]
That's kind of unpredictable,
but as it cascades
across the RI Lecture Theatre.
And then the tools
of the calculus.
Calculus gives us a mathematical
language to be able to analyse
a world in flux,
a changing world.
To be able to understand the
speed of this as it changes.
So, you know, Newton
gave scientists
that belief that maybe, yeah,
if we know the equations,
we know how the
universe is set up,
then everything is
just deterministic.
It just follows from
the mathematics.
So, Newton gave scientists
post-Newton that belief
that maybe we can
know the future
before it becomes the presence.
Laplace certainly
talked about that.
We have this thing,
Laplace's demon,
we just kind of says, yeah,
if you know the universe,
you'll know everything
into the future.
Well, if Newton is my
hero, then this guy here
is my nemesis in this story.
This is Henri Poincare
who discovered
the mathematics of chaos
theory at the beginning
of the 20th century.
And he explained how, even
if you do have the equations
and you have a very good
description of how the thing is
set up, just a very small error
can cause your predictions
to be completely untenable, and
something completely different
can happen.
And this can control
just very simple systems,
which you have the
equations for, can give rise
to incredibly complex behaviour.
And one of my favourite
examples is a pendulum.
So, actually, a
pendulum is usually
so predictable we use it
to keep track of time.
But this is a slightly different
pendulum I've got here.
It's called a double pendulum.
So, it's got two pieces
of metal jointed together
a little bit like a leg.
So, the geometry,
mathematics of this
is very simple to describe
these two pieces of metal.
The physics which controls
how this will fall
is also not that complicated.
But being able to use that to
protect the behaviour of this
thing is almost impossible.
[LAUGHTER]
Whoa!
Oh, look at that.
And I think the fact
that you're laughing
is a perfect example of the
fact that this is unpredictable.
Laughter is A
response to whoa, I
wasn't expecting that to happen.
But the real challenge of chaos
theory that Poincare raises is,
OK, that was very
complex behaviour,
but can I repeat the
exact same behaviour?
And actually, I have
a little notch here.
And I try and start the pendulum
off in exactly the same place.
So, let's see
whether-- if you can
remember what it did before.
Is it going to do--
[LAUGHTER]
Whoa.
That's already doing something
completely different.
I mean, it's still
quite funky, but--
OK, and then it seems to have--
this my favourite desktop toy.
I can play with this
for absolutely hours.
So, if you'll indulge me, I'm
just going to do one more--
[LAUGHTER]
--because it's just that--
Whoa.
Oh, whoa!
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, where did
that come from?
Unbelievable!
Whoa!
Give it a round of applause.
That's a--
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHS]
So, this is the challenge of
chaos theory is actually very
complex behaviour but it's being
able to repeat that behaviour.
So, I've got another
desktop toy, actually,
which I have on my desk at home.
It's again a pendulum.
But it's got six magnets
which attract the pendulum.
And over each
magnate is actually
an answer to a question.
So, I use this to make all my
decisions in life, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
So, you can ask it a question.
So, for example,
should I make a bet
on Arsenal beating
Swansea on Saturday?
So, we get-- I'm just going
to set this thing going.
So, the answer's are like try
again, no way, definitely,
maybe, yes, ask a friend.
So, here's a little
one we did in the lab.
So, this is an example
of this pendulum.
Oh, I've got just
three magnets here.
But you try and predict
which magnet the pendulum is
going to end up at.
I mean, I see this
wobble between them all.
Is it going to end
up at the top one?
And then right at the last,
it ends up at the bottom one.
But it seems incredible.
So, here we go.
Maybe.
Well, that's not good enough.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUMBLES] So, actually,
the challenge--
I mean, this is a bit like
an asteroid flying around,
and the magnets
are like planets.
And you've got to
try and decide, well,
which planet is going to get
wiped out by this asteroid?
In fact, Poincare
discovered this chaos theory
when he was trying to
understand the solar system
to see whether the solar
system was stable or not.
And what he-- oh,
it says definitely.
Great Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
It's always right.
And he understood that
even the solar system,
trying to predict whether
that is stable or not,
it's incredibly sensitive
to just very small changes
in where the asteroid is.
So, here's three
computer models that I
did of where the pendulum
is going to end up.
So, I've coloured those three
magnets yellow, red, and blue.
And I've started
the pendulum off
in the top left hand corner.
The first experiment, the thing
wiped out the blue planet.
But then, I changed the
sixth decimal place of one
of the coordinates of
the starting position.
So, you can't even
see that it's changed.
But when I then ran
the model, well, it
sort of followed the
same path for a while
and then completely
veered off and did
something completely different.
That time, it wiped
out the red planet.
Now, then I changed the
sixth decimal place again.
Again, a similar
sort of trajectory
to start with and then
wipes out the yellow planet.
So, that very small change
causes a massive difference
in the outcome.
And so, this is incredibly
difficult to predict.
Even though I have the equations
and I might have very accurate
knowledge about the
starting position,
unless I have
complete knowledge,
I really cannot know what
the answer is going to be.
And this computer graphic
helps you to try and make
a prediction about where
the pendulum will end up.
So, if I start the pendulum
over a yellow region,
that means that the
pendulum is going
to end up at the yellow magnet.
So, you can see there are some
regions which are knowable.
I mean, if you're--
so, the yellow magnet is sitting
under that big, yellow blob
there.
And sure enough, if
I start the magnet--
the pendulum next to
the yellow magnet,
then the other
two can't pull it.
And so, it's just going
to wobble and then
settle on the yellow magnet.
There's another area sort of
opposite the yellow magnet,
which if I start it there,
it's again, quite predictable.
A little error won't cause it to
do anything terribly different.
It will just swing
backwards and forwards,
and eventually, the
other two magnets
can't pull at either side.
It ends up again at
the yellow magnet.
But I started my pendulum
in the top left hand corner.
And this is an example of
something called a fractal.
So, a fractal are these
mathematical geometric shapes
which have infinite complexity.
So, as I zoom in on this
area, it never simplifies.
It never suddenly becomes,
oh, now, it's all yellow.
So, I know that if I've got
the accuracy up to this point,
I know it's going to
hit the yellow magnet.
It just keeps on being yellow,
blue, red, yellow, blue red.
As I zoom in, I try to get
more and more accurate.
Still, the 50th decimal
place can tip it over
from being yellow to blue.
So, this is a region which
says, if you're here,
you really cannot know what
is going to happen next.
So, you've got that
infinite sensitivity
to just a very small change.
call the butterfly effect.
Now, of course, the trouble
is that chaotic dynamics
affect so many things we would
like to know about the future.
The weather, for example,
the solar system,
even population dynamics.
And so, actually, I took
with me on my journey
to each of these edges an
expert in this area, somebody
who's been at this edge trying
to push it ever further.
So, the expert I took
actually on my journey
to try and predict the
future was a colleague
of mine in Oxford, Bob May who
is a mathematical biologist.
And he was one of the
people who understood
that population dynamics, a
very simple sort of feedback
equation, which controls the
population of animals from one
season to another, can also
have this incredible sensitivity
to small changes.
So, I went to go and talk
to him about his ideas.
Actually, he's now Lord May.
I shouldn't call him
Bob May, Lord May.
He's a cross-party member
of the House of Lords.
And he's actually working
with Andrew Haldane
at the Bank of England trying
to look now not at population
dynamics but at
the economy to see
whether the economy, the
equations for the economy--
it's just data and numbers and
kind of rules which control how
those numbers will evolve.
They're trying to see whether
the banking crisis of 2008
might have been a result of
very sort of chaotic motion
that would have been
very hard to predict.
So, he's actually
working with government,
trying to explain to
them the limitations
of being able to know
what's going to happen next,
even if you know the
theory which controls it.
And I went and had lunch with
him at the House of Lords,
and he made this statement to
me while we were having lunch.
He said, "Not only in research
but in the everyday world
of politics and economics, we
would be better off if more
people realised that simple
systems do not necessarily
possess simple
dynamic properties."
So, I asked him
how he was getting
on trying to explain some
mathematics of chaos theory
to the MPs at Westminster.
And he said, no, Marcus, they're
mostly interested in their egos
here, not in mathematics.
But then I came
back to this dice.
And I was intrigued.
Well, is the reason that
I can't know this dice
because the dynamics
are chaotic?
And I got a little
bit of a surprise.
I discovered a piece
of research that
had been done just recently
by some Polish mathematicians.
They've used high-speed
cameras to record
what the dice is doing as
it hits the table and rolls.
And they've actually understood
that in some circumstances
this is much more knowable
and you might think.
So, actually, I've coloured
the faces of the dice different
colours.
And we're going to draw
some similar pictures
to the one for predicting where
the pendulum is going to go,
which will help us to know
what arrangement of the dice
do I need to make it
land, say, on the red side
or the blue side.
So, here are the pictures
that the Polish team created.
And the interesting one is
the top left hand picture.
Because in this picture,
the colours are not fractal.
It's a very clear sort
of signal about where
this thing is going to land.
So, what this is
measuring on the two axes
is on one axis is the
height above the table,
and the other one is
the angle at which you
launch the dice from your hand.
And because this
picture isn't fractal,
it means that actually
a small change
isn't going to alter the side
that it's going to fall on.
So, the table that's
being described
in this particular
picture is a craps table,
which actually is quite soft.
And the dice dissipates a lot of
energy when it hits the table.
So, it's kind of like a bit of
an old, squidgy, craps table.
So, you know, perhaps a casino
that's seen better days.
So, this is the one that
you should go after.
Because it turns
out that actually
if the dice is losing a lot of
energy as it hits the table,
if it's a soft
table, then actually,
this thing is quite predictable.
And so, if you
take one thing away
from this talk and my book,
it's the following, OK?
More often than not,
there's a higher probability
that when you play
on such a table
that when you release the
dice, it will actually
land on the face which is
down on the palm of your hand
when you release it.
So, I wonder whether--
well, let's take this off.
Let's make a soft craps table.
Oh, gosh.
Yes, no, I have to--
I forgot-- well, I'll try
and get dressed in a bit.
So, let's make
this kind of soft.
And let's see whether
we can make this work.
All right, so, OK.
So, I'm going to have
the six on the bottom.
So, I'm going to
try and get a six.
So, I'm going to let this fall.
Oh, it's a one.
Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, that's a bit rough.
That's why I chose
maths, you know?
The proofs make sure
all these things work.
But actually, you
know, of course,
it's a probabilistic thing.
So, more than likely, so,
one in six times that works.
[LAUGHTER]
But as the table gets
more and more rigid,
so, the table I got here
is a very rigid table,
and it bounces a lot.
This is described by
the pictures which are
becoming more and more fractal.
So, it says that on this table,
again, a very small change,
that butterfly
effect we call it,
a very small change can cause it
to go from the four to the six
to the one.
And again, it says that you
cannot know what this dice d
going to do next.
Now, that edge is actually under
very classical 19th century
ideas of science.
But of course in
the 20th century,
we realised that maybe the
universe isn't as predictable
and deterministic as
Newton actually thought.
And so, the next edge
I'm going to take
you to is the edge
which we discovered
at the beginning
of the 20th century
that maybe actually
unknowability
is actually at the heart of
the way we must do science.
And this is the science
of quantum physics.
So, quantum physics almost has
embedded in it the fact that
you cannot know.
And so, the object I took
with me on my journey
to the edge of the quantum
was this pot of uranium,
which I bought on the internet.
[LAUGHTER]
It's amazing what you can buy
on the internet these days.
So, the interesting thing
about this pot of uranium
is that on the side, it
tells me the activity.
So, it tells me that there are
984 per minute, on average,
there are 984 bits of
radiation being kicked off--
oh, I probably
shouldn't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
There are 984 bits of
radiation being kicked off
this uranium per minute.
But that's on average.
And what this pot can't tell
me, and in fact what physics
at the moment cannot tell us,
cannot know is when it's going
to do that.
There is no mechanism
currently known,
and it's believed that
there is no mechanism,
it's a fundamental part
of the way we do physics,
that there is no mechanism
which would tell me
when the radiation is
going to get kicked off.
OK?
On average 984, but when
is it going to do it?
It seems to be totally random.
We don't seem to
be able to know.
And this is at the
heart of something
you've probably heard of,
Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle.
principle kind of articulates
the fact that we cannot
know certain things.
So, Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle
says that, for example, if I
want to know where an elec--
I'm trying to
describe an electron.
And if I'm trying to
do Newtonian physics,
I need to know where
the electron is
and how it's moving.
So, I need to know
it's momentum.
But Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle
says, well, actually, you
can't know both of those things
simultaneously.
That the more you know
about where the electron is,
the less you can know
about how it's moving.
So, this is actually-- it's
not a wishy-washy statement.
It's a very precise
mathematical formula.
It actually comes out
of the mathematics.
And the formula
I've written here
is that the delta
x is the error.
So, the error is getting
smaller and smaller.
I know more and more about
where that electron is.
To make this equation work,
the error in the momentum,
it means that
momentum can suddenly
have a whole range of
different possible values.
And if I get to know--
so, you might say, oh,
I know where the
electron is now.
So, now, I'm going to
measure its momentum.
Well, as you get to know more
about how that thing's moving,
you suddenly lose
knowledge again.
Suddenly, the electron
could be anywhere
as the error gets
larger and larger.
So, if you'll indulge me, my
favourite physics joke is about
Heisenberg.
So, Heisenberg is bombing
down the motorway in his BMW.
And the police pull him over.
The policeman gets
Heisenberg out of the car
and says to him, sir, do you
know how fast you were going?
[LAUGHTER]
And Heisenberg says, no, but
I know exactly where I was.
[LAUGHTER]
Good, yeah, you're a
good audience, you see.
So, anyone who's sort of sitting
there saying, why were they
laughing?
That wasn't funny.
You shouldn't have to
explain a joke, I know.
But the point is because
he knew exactly where he
was, it meant that
there was an uncertainty
about the different values
that his speed could have been.
So, it could be in a whole
range of different values.
So, here's the
follow-up to the joke.
So, the police
officers says, you
were going 200
kilometres per hour.
And Heisenberg goes, oh!
Now we're lost.
[LAUGHTER]
More people getting that one.
Yes, exactly.
So, because we now know
how fast he was going,
he's lost information
about his position.
There's a third bit to the joke.
You can ask me in the questions.
The follow-up to that one.
But Schrodinger happens to
be in the back of the car.
[LAUGHTER]
But actually, modern physics
has a different interpretation
about this.
It actually says, well, maybe
it's kind of our language
which is wrong.
That actually this
electron doesn't
have a position and a
momentum at the same time.
That's a very sort of old
Newtonian classical way
of thinking about it.
Actually, we should think
that this thing doesn't have
a position until we observe it.
So, actually, we have this
thing called the quantum wave
function.
So, this kind of tells
you the likelihood
of finding where
the electron is.
But it actually isn't there.
It doesn't have a
position until you make
the commitment of observing it.
And then it collapses into
a position, and the waves
sort of-- if the
wave is high, it
says you're more
likely to find it here.
If it's low, it says,
no, very unlikely.
But there is a chance
that you'll find it there.
Now, I find this
totally unsatisfactory.
It's because, you
know, my feeling is
that you do an experiment, if
you set it up the same way,
you're going to get the
same answer each time.
This says, no, you're
just not going to know.
You can set up the
same experiment,
do it over and over again.
And each time you
do it, the electron
can do something
completely different.
So, there's no determinism here.
There's no mechanism
which is going
to say where it's going to be.
And actually, this
controls the--
it's the same sort
of mechanism which
is at the heart of explaining
the radiation of this uranium.
So, actually, I know quite
a lot about the momentum
of the bound particles
inside the nucleus
of the uranium, which means I
know less about the position.
The position can be on a
whole range of possibilities.
And when we observe
it, sometimes
that position can be-- most of
the times it's still inside.
But sometimes it can be outside,
this thing called tunnelling.
And then it radiates.
So, this kind of
indeterminacy is actually
at the heart of
explaining the radiation.
But I just cannot believe
there isn't something that we
haven't found yet, something
that will tell us when
it's going to do that.
I mean, is it genuinely
something that we cannot know?
Or is it just that
physicists have given up,
and it's, you know, this
theory works very well.
So, why do we need to bother
because it tells us everything
we need to know.
And I'm not alone in
thinking that surely this
is actually not genuinely
something we don't know.
It's just that we haven't
had the revolution which
would give us the mechanism.
And Einstein was certainly
a believer in this
being not the final answer.
He wrote very famously, "Quantum
mechanics is very impressive.
But an inner voice tells me that
it is not yet the real thing.
The theory produces a
good deal, but it hardly
brings us closer to the
secret of the old one.
I am at all events convinced
that he does not play dice."
And it is certainly true
that theory is probably
one of the most well
tested theories that we
have on the scientific books.
You know, to use this
theory of probability
and quantum physics
is good enough
for nearly everything
you want to do.
But surely there's
something going
on inside this uranium,
which is controlling
when it's going to radiate.
We now know, of course, that
this mechanism, if it exists,
is a very weird one.
The idea of entanglement has
made us understand that it
won't be kind of localised
inside the uranium.
It will be something
which actually
spans the whole universe
which is controlling
the decision about when this
is going to radiate or not.
But is there a mechanism?
Maybe there isn't, and maybe
this is genuinely something we
cannot know.
Now, I said that I was
going to kind of tease out
a little bit of implications
of the unknown for the idea
of religion and god.
And so, I was quite
interested to talk
to some scientists who
are actually religious
and see what their belief--
how did they marry
up their ideas
of doing science and religion.
And the person I
took on my journey
to the edge of the
quantum world is actually
an interesting scientist.
It's John Polkinghorne.
John Polkinghorne,
a quantum physicist,
trained with the best,
trained with Feynman, Dirac.
Can't ask for better
teachers than those two.
But then half way
through his career,
he decided he wanted
to be ordained
as a priest in the
Church of England.
He kind of refers
to himself as kind
of like a vegetarian butcher.
[LAUGHTER]
But I was kind of interested
because, you know, for me,
it actually was quite remarkable
how many of the scientists
I talked to had some
sort of religious belief.
But I think there are two
sort of religious scientists.
There are the deists
and the theists.
The deists are those
who say, for example,
one of the big unknowns is,
where did all of this stuff
come from?
What created all
of this, you know,
this table, this
dice, the pendulum?
Where did it all come from?
And many scientists-- we just
do not know the answer to that.
We don't know the
answer to that.
And some people will call the
answer to that, that unknown--
look, I don't know the answer.
I'm just going to call that
the god which created it.
And we might find out more
about what that god is.
But that's what I'm calling god.
And now I'm a scientist,
and I do my science.
And I don't think this
thing acts in the world
and changes it.
So, those are the deists.
And I think probably Einstein,
when he talks about god,
is thinking more about that
kind of idea of the unknown.
But Polkinghorne is
slightly more interesting
because he's a theist.
These are people who believe
that their god actually acts
in the world and transforms
it and changes it
and that maybe you can actually
help influence this god
to change the world.
So, I was interested
to talk to him about,
well, OK, you're a scientist.
How is your science
actually working
to actually have some sort
of action in the world?
And I wondered, as
a quantum physicist,
whether he might see that sort
of unknown of quantum physics
as a window of opportunity
for an external force
to actually make some action.
Because if actually
within the system
we can never know where the
electron is going to be,
then maybe that's an
opportunity for something
external to be
going, OK, well, now
I'm going to put
the electron there.
Because chaos theory actually
means that a very small change
can have a big outcome.
Maybe actually, where
the electron will go
can cause quite a big
effect on the outcome.
But Polkinghorne didn't
go for quantum physics.
He said, well, no, that
still depends on an observer.
You have to observe the setting
in order for the wave function
to collapse.
And he didn't believe
that sort of god
would be waiting for--
his god would be waiting
for observations to happen.
And he actually
chose chaos theory
as his little kind of
window of the unknown
for his god to act in the world.
So, he believes
that as humans we
can never know how a system
is completely set up.
So, there will always
kind of be decimal places
which are unknown
where you can actually
start to tinker with
things and actually
have an effect on the system.
And you don't have
to affect things
like conservation of energy.
That it's still possible to move
the system, conserve energy.
And he believed that that
might be a place for his god
to act in the world.
Interestingly, this
is not a new idea.
Newton himself, also a
very religious scientist,
also believed that it
was in the decimals
that his god could actually
change and affect the world.
And he had a big
fight with Leibniz--
he had many fights with Leibniz
over the calculus and things
like that.
But one of his fights, Leibniz
said, well, I don't get it.
Why wouldn't God have
set up the system
to be sort of perfect
in the first go?
I mean, why does he
need to interact-- or he
or she or it need to
interact with the thing?
So, it's interesting that
it's not a kind of new idea
to use the ideas of those small
changes can have big effects.
But for me, one of
the interesting things
is that quantum physics
actually might give us
an answer to one of
those big unknowns, which
I think is responsible
for many people
being religious, which is well,
where did all of this stuff
come from?
I mean, for example,
my port of uranium,
where did that come from?
Well, I bought it
on Amazon, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
And it was amazing.
You know you can write
reviews underneath.
So, some of the
reviews are amazing.
One guy said, so glad I don't
have to buy this from Libyans--
[LAUGHTER]
--in parking lots
at the mall anymore.
There was one who was
complaining that said,
I've had this for 4 billion
years, and it's half full.
[LAUGHTER]
I see-- I love when you
get the half-life jokes.
But no, where did
this come from?
OK, well, it came from
a mine, ultimately.
Somebody dug it up from a mine.
But OK.
But where did the uranium
come from in the mine?
Well, we now know
that that uranium
had to be created inside
a supernova crushing
all of these particles
together to fuse them
into this very heavy atom.
But then, where did
all of those electrons
and the protons and the neutrons
come, which slam together?
Well, you know, if
you work it back,
then you're back
to the Big Bang.
And you're like,
well, yeah, so, where
did all of these
particles come from?
Well, it's possible that quantum
physics might have an answer.
Because Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle
applies to different
sorts of measurements.
I told you the one about
position and momentum.
But there are other things
which are bound together
in a kind of
uncertainty principle.
And the other two that are
interesting in this case
are energy and time.
So, it means,
actually, that it's not
possible to have a true vacuum.
Because remember energy
e equals mc squared.
So, energy is actually
equivalent to mass.
So, if you actually
narrow the window of time,
it means there's an uncertainty
in the energy because
of this uncertainty principle.
So, it means that you can never
have a region of space which
is truly a vacuum.
Because in each very
small window of time,
that can't be set
to zero, the energy,
because there has to be
an uncertainty there.
So, sometimes the energy can
have a positive value, which
can give rise to particles.
So, it's a little bit like
thinking of the equation 0
equals 1 plus, minus 1.
So, 0 sort of suddenly
turns into a particle
and an antiparticle, which
very often just annihilate
each other, and it goes
back to the zero state.
But sometimes
those can separate,
and so you can get
something out of nothing.
Actually, this is at the
heart of Hawking's discovery
of radiation from a black hole.
That actually on the event
horizon of a black hole,
you can get these quantum
fluctuations happening such
that a particle forms on one
side and an anti-particle
on the other.
And then they can't
actually get to each other.
Particle emits,
the anti-particle
starts to degrade
the black hole.
And it's a way that black
holes can actually sort
of start to sort of seep away.
The rate is so small
that at the moment
we haven't observed it, which
is why he hasn't won the Nobel
Prize yet.
But once there's an
observation made of it,
that will probably follow.
So, it's the same principle
about why black holes are
actually radiating.
So, you know, actually, if
you think about it, OK, still,
empty space isn't nothing.
That isn't really nothing.
Where did the empty
space come from?
It's a three-dimensional
space or maybe
an 11-dimensional space.
So, where did that come from?
You've still got to answer that.
OK, once you've got space,
it might have fluctuations
which give rise to particles.
But now, sort of ideas
of quantum gravity
are beginning to give
us even the possibility
that fluctuations
in quantum gravity
can give us space out
of genuinely nothing.
So, it's interesting that
quantum physics might be a way
to answer one of the
really big unknowns, which
causes a lot of people, I think,
to have to create a creator.
So, that was a
little exploration
into the edges of the
unknown of quantum physics.
So, I'll give you a
little whizzy guided tour.
How are we doing?
We've got 10 minutes left.
Good, OK.
So, we've got to do five
great unknowns in 10 minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, my god.
Wow, I set myself a challenge.
So, one of the things
I was intrigued in
is, OK, what is the
uranium made out of.
Because uranium-- OK, so, I've
mentioned electrons, protons,
and neutrons.
So, but actually, the electrons
we believe are indivisible.
But what about the
protons and neutrons?
You know, at one
point, we thought
atoms were kind of invisible.
Then they pulled apart into
these electrons, protons,
and neutrons.
And then the
protons and neutrons
we discovered are
not indivisible.
They've pulled apart,
and we now know
there are quarks at
the heart of those.
And that, we think,
is the invisible bits
which build all of matter.
But that's our generation.
And as my book sort
of illustrates,
I go through the
history of science,
and we just see
each new generation
has a different story
about the next layer down.
So, how can I ever know actually
that I've hit the last layer?
How do I know that
there won't be another--
the quarks will come
apart into something else,
and those will come apart
into something else.
So, can I ever know that
I've hit the last layer?
Is that actually an unknown?
Because maybe it's
turtles, all the way down.
You know, so--
[LAUGHTER]
So, the unknown are the very
small and also the very big.
What about the universe?
Is the universe infinite?
If it is, is that something
we could ever know?
We can explore the universe.
But actually,
Einstein has given us
a kind of limit on
what we can actually
see about our universe.
So, let me take it into here.
There's a kind of cosmic horizon
surrounding us beyond which we
cannot actually know anything.
Because information travels
at the speed of light.
The universe has been going
for 13.8 billion years.
That means actually, we can only
have received a finite amount
of information coming into us.
That bubble beyond
that, no information
could have reached us.
So, we can't know anything
about beyond that bubble.
Now, that bubble is growing.
So, we're sort of
seeing more and more.
But we'll only ever
see a finite bit.
So, how can we ever
know it's infinite?
But not only that.
It turns out the universe is
accelerating in its expansion.
It's actually pushing things
over our cosmic horizons.
So, as time goes on, we
are actually seeing less.
We're going to get to a point
where actually all the galaxies
are pushed over the horizon.
We'll come back to
a very ancient kind
of view of our universe
that we are just
one galaxy in a massive void.
So, I think that's
quite a challenge.
Could we ever know that the
universe is infinite, if it is?
So, that was the very big.
I think one of the other
great unknowns is time.
The question of what
happened before the Big Bang.
Could we ever know that?
It's a singularity.
We can't know.
The math denies us access
to time before the Big Bang.
Will time go on forever,
or does it have an end?
It turns out, it seems like
time is actually finite.
Now, I used to--
I grew up with the
belief that you can't
ask what's before the Big Bang.
But there are a kind of rumbles
in the cosmological corridors
that actually, maybe
we can answer that one.
We can talk about what
happened before the Big Bang.
So, time is still one
of the big mysteries.
Actually, the last
edge I talk about
is my own area of mathematics,
which was actually partly
an inspiration for
this whole book.
Because in my area
of mathematics,
we actually have a proof of
the limitations of our tools.
It's something called Godel's
incompleteness theorem,
which says that there are true
statements about mathematics
which you cannot prove are
true within your system
of mathematics.
So, actually, we've been able
to prove there are things which
are true which we
cannot prove are true.
[LAUGHTER]
Which is amazing.
So, that was partly
my inspiration.
But I think the
penultimate edge--
well, I've got five minutes
to tell you about this--
which I think is a
really interesting one.
Because it goes to the
heart of who we are.
And this is the question of the
hard problem of consciousness.
What is it that makes us
have a sense of ourselves
inside our bodies?
Is that something
we can ever know?
And actually, the
object I took--
I mean, I think
the real challenge,
Wittgenstein kind
of summed it up.
Consciousness is a
little bit like--
we've all got this box.
And inside it,
there is something
we've all called a beetle.
But nobody can look
in anybody else's box.
And so, we don't know
whether your beetle
is anything like my beetle.
And this is a real challenge.
You know, you're all
conscious, I hope.
I mean, some of you are looking
a little bit dazed by now--
oh, it's quite late.
[LAUGHTER]
But you know, I assume
you're all conscious.
This kind of idea
of homogeneity.
You're all quite like me.
So, I assume your consciousness
is quite like my own.
But how can I
actually know that?
How can I actually be sure
that tonight you haven't all
sent your avatars
along to this lecture
and in fact you're all at
home sort of catching up
on Poldark or something.
In fact there isn't
any-- you know,
doing a very good impression
of a conscious being.
But how can I actually know
that there's anything going on.
And I think this is the
real challenge, you know,
of actually
understanding firstly,
what it is-- what is it
about putting electrons
and protons and
neutrons together which
gives a sense of self?
And secondly, how
can I ever know
that somebody else has that?
As I said, I think you're
all fairly similar to me.
But what about my iPhone?
I mean, where is my iPhone?
So, actually, the object I
took with me on my journey
to the edge of
consciousness was an app
that I downloaded on my iPhone.
And what it does,
it's a chat bot app.
So, I talk to it, and
it talks back to me.
And it kind of
tries to be human.
It's trying to pass
the Turing test.
And maybe it is.
Maybe there's somebody on the
other end of the line actually
typing these things in.
And that's the
kind of challenge.
How can I know whether
that's conscious or not?
Remember the granny who always
put very polite words in Google
because she assumed that
somebody was actually
answering these questions?
Please could you tell me the--
But I think the real
challenge of consciousness
and the challenge at
the heart of this edge
is actually, well,
how could I ever know
that this has become conscious?
How can I know that the
activity inside this
actually got a sense of self?
You know, how--
suddenly, it declares,
iPhone think,
therefore iPhone am.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, my gosh.
Wow, you know, I'd better
not switch it off tonight.
So, I think that the
challenge of consciousness
is potentially one which,
by its very nature,
maybe is protected.
Because I can't ever feel
what it's like to be you.
We will call this a red dice.
But is your sense of
red anything like mine?
Pain, if you stub your toe, is
that pain anything like mine?
How can we actually quantify
what it feels like to be you?
We certainly got to a very
exciting stage where, you know,
it's a bit like being
Galileo with a telescope.
Suddenly, the universe
has opened up to him.
We do have telescopes
into the mind.
We can actually see the
activity of the mind at work
and when it's asleep.
And those tools have given
us many things that we can
tease out about consciousness.
And it's interesting you
mentioned Francis Crick
because Francis Crick,
after doing DNA--
consciousness was
something no scientist
would go anywhere near.
It was regarded as something
that you couldn't know.
It was the domain
of the philosophers
and the theologians.
But Francis Crick said,
no, actually, maybe we
can know much more about this.
And the person I
took on my journey
to the edge of consciousness
was actually this guy here,
Christof Koch, who
worked with Francis Crick
right at the beginning of
his work on consciousness
when it was a very
untrendy thing to do.
But the kind of
insights we've got
are beginning to give
us some sort of idea
of what it is about the
network in the brain which
might actually answer the
question of consciousness.
But actually, so, I've met
Christof many times in America.
I've had him over to
Oxford to give talks.
But my last
interaction with him,
we had a Skype call together
where I kind of really pushed
him.
OK, you might know all of these
correlates of consciousness.
But can you ever really know
that something is conscious?
And maybe that is
an unanswerable.
And he got very angry with me.
And he kind of shouted
down the Skype call-- well,
I assume it was him.
Maybe it was an avatar that
he uses too, But he said,
"What sort of research
programme is it, Marcus,
where you throw up your hands
and say, forget about it.
I can't understand it
ever, it's hopeless.
That's defeatism."
And I think actually, it's
the mindset of the scientist,
and it's an important mindset,
that we go into every challenge
actually thinking there
is nothing we cannot know.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
You have a distinction between
something that doesn't exist
and something we don't know.